Billie Jean King, already a champion of women's rights,...
...is now the most successful female player of all time.
I am not saying that women don't belong on the court.
Who would pick up the balls otherwise?
Oh my God.
There isn't a single thing I don't hate about Bobby Riggs.
You know what I'm doing?
I'm cooking.
I won the triple at Wimbledon.
I could beat Billie Jean King.
Does she have the nerve?
Call Bobby.
Tell him it's on.
So, Billie Jean, what do you want?
But don't get me wrong, I love women in the bedroom and in the kitchen.
Keep talking, Bobby.
The more nonsense you spout, the worse it's gonna be when you lose.
I'm gonna be the best.
That way, I can really change things.
Ladies and gentlemen, I'm going to put the "show" back in chauvinism.
Bobby's a clown.
This whole thing is an act for him.
Business, sports, you name it, at the very top, it's a man's world.
It's when we want a little bit of what you've got, that's what you can't stand.
Forty million people are watching the battle you've all been waiting to see.
I'm done talking, let's play.
The Battle of the Sexes.